all right hello everyone we are back to
talking about multi-computation and the
theory is that Nick here has now done
the things we were hoping for in the
last few weeks and so we're going to be
able to talk productively about
multi-computational programming
so
Nick you're with us yeah okay good
um all right and this is
a um documentation all right
so let's see what we got here
uh
you may want to get the bucket
in order to use not the pocket symbols
but the symbols directly
maybe maybe
let's let's look at what you have here
to begin with okay
so
so this is based on the hypergraph
conversion things that I showed you
previously
it's like all the systems that
potentially multi-way system can support
system types
uh that doesn't look very promising did
it
what do I do here is there an update
that I have to run
maybe for the muchiki place
okay well it came up with some update
mechanism there update
why did it beep
this is not good
opportunity to test things as always
what's that
is this updated or is it not why is it
beeping
oh I don't know
you should just type resource function
and multi-replace yeah and do it outside
of the message
latest oh it's already updated
2.10 2.1 confused
what's happened here
I'm guessing the issue is that it was
trying to update the instance of the
multi-year place that appeared inside of
the message and for some reason it
couldn't do that
I was trying to update it
what's Happening Here
well these messages
do you just run it again yes I did
somehow it looks like it's resolved
multi-replaced to be version 2.0
or just quit the kernel and do it again
I don't even get should work
and let's try this again
I thought that's better
okay
all right
okay
so that picture does that picture have
anything to do with what's up just a
random icon
that's not good that's not good it's not
good we can't use that I know I know
it's just a placeholder
it's like an official thing
but it's not completed yet here
okay so if I now stay so for this rule
this is a lazy multi-object is that
correct
yeah but I'm not losing any lazy things
have been developing
it's using that multi-object that
they've been showing
okay so everything compiled into
hypergraphs underneath
but that's weird really
and yeah
are you using sort of existing wolfen
model code for the hypergraph so you're
using something different there
different I'm using the Wolfram model
for if you actually have a rule
with the hypergraph so we will have a
buffer module then I'm using table from
model object
but everything else as expressions
I'm using just a multi replace
after compiling it into the Expressions
to hypergraphs
so wait a second you're doing the
hypergraph thing so that you can be
clear on what the causal relationships
are is that right so that's it's like
much easier to write custom systems
okay so let me understand in in this
case for example what's the output what
what's the thing you know there should
be a a state Evolution function a state
equivalence function
is that correct
I don't maybe I I'm not introduced them
yet for Simplicity
right
go ahead right now all you oh it's
happening what is happening is you
compile your rules and initial condition
to hypergraph
right and then some you just applying
this rule over and over again and
there's some properties that extract
useful graphs out of it okay but when
you turn a string into a hypergraph what
is it turning into it's turning into
some kind of oh I see there it is one a
two two a three so it's a linked list
yep
and does that give the same causal
properties as everything we've had so
far about about strings
there may there may be some differences
in a way I construct the chromograph
yeah but I can defend my position on
that it's like what is the difference or
why is the elephants there
well fine I think Athena might be here
and she might find it interesting to try
and unravel what's actually going on
between hypographs and uh and ordinary
strings
um
but okay so this yes
I'm trying to understand actually how
this how with what algorithm does it
does this create is this created like
how is this connected with the
with the rules above with a graph above
when the this object is is created
that's that's for example I mean so
what's supposed to be happening is a a
is transformed by this rule a goes to ba
into Aba
and so presumably that rule a goes to ba
has turned into blank a blank
or n blank a m blank you can actually
show the rules if you ask for multi
rules property
okay
multi-rules
what was it called because it's not
showing up in Providence list here well
it's a kind of sub property of a much
object because
no no just no not like it it's like just
to ask for a multi object and you can
ask for rules or you can just ask rules
directly because all the sub properties
are automatically propagated oh my gosh
what is this
this is just it kind of looks like a
rule right but I kind of applying this
is only a first outermost rule for the
much object but this rule acts as like
like a function
right it applies this function to each
hypograph and then this is like the
second argument to this apply hypergraph
rules is an actual hypergraph rules
but they look a little bit weird in
order to free to work for arbitrary
hypergraphs is this code efficient
though it's as efficient as maybe as
subset positions
is efficient
well I mean but but this has all kinds
of extra stuff it's doing with splice
and so on
well that's the right hand side maybe
the bottleneck is actually actually
finding the left hand side and the list
of hybridges I think
and then this one would be as efficient
as subset position would find them
okay but here's the rule of relevance
you know it's a linked list and it's got
its tentacles hanging out here and I
mean this is doing what I would kind of
expect it to do that is it's taking in
the main list and it's kind of nice
actually it's very explicit here in the
main list it's splicing this result in
having re-jiggered these with a new
module variable for that hyper Edge
right
right
okay okay thank you
um
okay and and okay so let's I mean this
is quite nice this is quite a um uh you
know I want to see what it does with
expressions and so on
yeah
you can go there
okay well let's just understand
you can look two tips look up the two
events
because they have more information
okay can we get a token event graph from
this thing
uh not yet well there's no tokens except
there are tokens you can use you
shattered everything into tokens those
are tokens right
so if High page is a token 10 year we
can they can make a token recovery but
high prices are tokens I mean that's
what in the standard wolf model setup
hyper edges are exactly tokens
right but you may be like equivalent
then we would the Cleveland's
equivalence those tokens of as well only
by payroll so as a second argument in
those list
Maybe
there's some subjects
how you would make no I understand I
understand so the question is what is
the state equivalence function look like
a token will kill events
right okay so there's okay just just to
be clear
when we look at one of these graphs
there are two fundamental operations
going on there is State evolution
what state time like follows What other
state
that's thing number one
thing number two
and I don't know that I can do that with
this code is it's all treed out there
are no equivalences that is the two
different ways to get to baa are
distinct
all right so you must have a thing that
explicitly equivalences a baa with
different hyper Edge names of different
different connector names right you've
got to equivalence those two baas with
different connector names down to a
single baa there
actually
well States graph I already
make this equivalence no no I understand
that I'm saying there is an explicit
action look the whole point is that in
in like you know the story of quantum
mechanics
is a story of essentially Observers
you know making equivalences between
things which we would look at them and
say these are identical right
but in the original generation of this
and you see that very explicitly with
your formalism here they are not
equivalent they have different connector
names
right
the name of the of the you should know
canonical as the hypergraph so
I understand that I understand that so
when you've canonicalized it that's a
way of doing State equivalence is you
canonicalize and then you say the ones
that are canonically identical are the
same
right yeah because in in its in its
natural state this is just a tree it
just you know applies this Rule and
nothing equivalence is anything and in
fact my guess is that the the sort of
the outside view of the universe is
that's what's happening just giant treed
out thing and it's it's merely in the
eye of the Observer that different
branches that are that we we would
consider equivalent because they're for
example isomorphic hypographs are
equivalents together and that's what
you're doing here but I think we need to
explicitly introduce this notion of a
state equivalence function because I
mean we've had that in the old multi-way
code and we need to make it more cleaner
here and I I don't know what the state
equivalence function is for you here
what is it
typograph it's almost like canonical
hypograph but it also knows about the
payroll
it's kind of ignore it
right this is a this is a canonicalizer
that ignores the connectors and looks
only at the payload
right
it canonicalizes the connectors because
they are I see I see okay vertices and
typograph
y fine so you you remove the payload
then you run the usual canonical
hypograph and then you put the payroll
back appropriately
okay okay fine all right
well I mean we we clearly need nice
clean functions to do that because I
think that's going to be a critical
thing as we look at all these other
other examples okay but let's keep
looking at this so we don't yet have a
token event graph but we could have one
sure yeah right
yeah and that two chip in the for the
events you kind of see that there's a
three position
this actually the two position is
positioned in the multi-oh tree
before you do any equivalent setup
so in order to make a photograph you
actually have to make a tree
so that you have events even they're
doing the same actually the same thing
but in a separate branches you still
have separate separately you have two
events
but there's an event equivalence
function as well isn't there
yeah we can reproduce that too
because ultimately when you've
equivalenced all the events and all the
states I believe you have a petri net
or is it equivalencing of events only
I've forgotten
maybe it's equivalency of events you get
a battery net anybody know
it's not obvious
I did describe that in the in the room
yet
thing I wrote actually I'm forgetting
what is the difference between position
and tree position
opposition is a little bit
you can ignore it it's like an extra
thing actually doesn't mean anything
it's a position of the hyper rage in the
list it's been a quite but because
hypergraphs are unordered this position
actually doesn't mean anything but I'd
still record it
yes
right so in other words Ian translating
in the way we're doing hypergraphs it is
a it is just a vat of hyper edges there
is no sense in which there is ordering
of the hyper edges
the diverges are assembled go ahead
it's clear here that it's like actual
position of a character that it's been
applied to after canonicalizing it I
think it's going to hold
position of a high pressure that the
rule has been applied to always be the
same as a position of a character
I see I was wondering if tree position
should just be called position but then
I saw that you already had a position
yeah well but I I think these names are
not right yet I mean because okay let me
just understand the street position
concept
so
first of all can I generate the pure
tree for this thing
um
if you extract the multi object and ask
for graph it will essentially make a
graph without any equivalent so so all
right so let's let's like the multi of
this
and the graph from that yeah
that was uninspiring
well well you asked for it free
steps
similar as above where do I want to put
the three here on the graph after the
graph
nice okay so if I do this
and I say graph
vertex labels Arrow
automatic
oh gosh
yeah those are the hypergraphs before
any clinicalization
right what is this Matrix form oh yeah
it's all messed up I mean if I say x
blank
at least let me make them into
I don't know what I should make them
into grids Maybe
maybe just input form
I don't know well I think input form is
going to be
okay let's do two steps
all right
that's our initial strain
as a hyper graph
um
right so then
in particular this thing here baa
is I don't know which ones it is but
it's two of these edges
and okay so now when you label an event
are you labeling that event by its Edge
I mean the event
is one of these edges isn't it every one
of these edges has an event associated
with it yep
and
uh where do I put this is this a
multi-computation
yes
I mean ideas meetings in SW notes
you can save it there
oh okay fine
um
uh
okay so every one of these edges is an
event
and your labeling of events is based on
so what we're doing here in this case
is
the events represent separate edges in
the tree
but the states have been equivalenced
right were we to put events on here we
just decorate every edge with an event
yep something like that
okay so there isn't a unique okay so the
events are unique relative to the
original tree
I believe that event equivalencing as I
say will lead to the patronettes but now
let's understand what you mean by so
you've got an event
and I don't understand your creator
Destroyer thing
well that's the exactly what woofer
model is doing I know that I know that I
want to understand that in your context
so
oh I see what you're saying is this
event
is destroying a particular hyper Edge
and creating another hyper Edge
yeah and what it's an inventory chords
is the first element of a hybrid it's
link
that's pretty random why isn't it just
recording the whole hyper Edge
no because it's Unique
the the link of each hybrid that was the
first element there
is unique for each hybrid so whenever
you pattern match against it
you assume it's being destroyed and then
you
pretty much the right hand side so you
can recreate it or the new hyper Edge
being introduced to the new link and
then you know what links are newly
introduced and that will be created okay
but okay so you're saying your created
mechanism is labeling
okay so that's creating hyper edges
tagged as two and eight
and
that's an example of the a goes to
whatever it is then because as we can
see there a goes to ba because
destroying one hyper Edge and creating
two hyper edges
and this here
is destroying two hyper edgers and
creating two high bridges
yeah the same ones
well yes there's a turn well except that
I don't understand that because I don't
understand how it can reuse two and
three there I don't understand I thought
you said that every hyper-edge label was
unique
no within one Arrow application you can
recreate the same high bridge
I think it's
it's not forbidden it's okay because
then you
uh the other causal
connections then would be
drawn based on the what is created and
what's destroyed relative to two pairs
of events
yeah
the causal connection has to label it
has to I I this seems wrong to me
because the causal connection has to go
from a
uh Destroyer to a creator
right every causal every event
has incoming destruction you know
incoming edges from its Destroyer
tokens from its destroyed tokens and
outgoing edges to its created tokens
right
yeah
so I don't understand how it can have
the same named tokens that are being
both destroyed and created unless that
were a loop in the in the causal graph
oh it's one that went
if you give me pair of events I can then
compare the destroyed and create it
links and see whether they connect it
causally or not
oh I see what you're saying
um
so your point is
okay so here for example
I understand this at all why is the
three
look this Edge
that edge there could be labeled with
the these tags that represent what
information it is carrying
from the destruction of Syrian Navy
you have two events there why they're
causally connected because one of events
above created link number three which
the second one below destroyed I know
but but that destroyed three in that
first event
what's that doing
I will understand what you just said but
why is there a three why is there
another three being destroyed in in that
first event
well why not
because it's confusing I mean how does
it know to connect this three that's in
the you know the the to the three that's
destroyed in the next event rather than
the three that was destroyed in that
first event well they're all connected
because Kozo grass has this transitive
property right you can
even if though another event above that
also created this thing
link number three it's also going to be
connected closely to the one below it
right well so then you're doing a
Transit reduction on the scruff
well I'm not doing it because there's no
actual event if there were event that
created the
link number three that would be another
the cause of age
all the all causal radius are created
for all player events so if you first
you make all this all all set of events
you make a set of cool events and then
you just compare them pairwise
yeah I understand to find out what
you're causally connected but well I
don't understand
I thought you were telling me that these
are non-canonicalized events I mean
non-colonicalized States
so those states have in them connectors
which are you know one the first one
might be one two the second one might be
uh three four
Etc et cetera et cetera that every state
has not been canonicalized with respect
to its connector nodes is that not
correct
well this states that you're looking at
right now they're they're kind of
equalized this picture was it created
tough to make a causal graph I
understand so I understand that these
are being canonicalized to remove out
the hypograph aspect of it but the
hypographs from which that was
canonicalized
there are whatever it is some number of
different typograph well in that
particular case there was only one but
down here there were two different
typographs that were canonicalized to
the same thing correct
and
I don't understand here so this one here
am I just being being dumb here I mean
is this what's what's
I don't understand how these labels in
these events
are these after the canonicalization of
the hypergraphs
because I don't understand otherwise why
these have such small ID numbers like
three and so on when the New Orleans
I don't remember but some in some sense
you can
get rid of those unique links that have
been created randomly when you create a
new hyper Edge okay but let's understand
what's going on here so we've got the
pure tree picture okay in the pure tree
picture every edge of the tree is an
event
okay
and then
in order to find out the causal
connection between events
what are we doing what is our procedure
the event here is one that destroys
some hyper edges in this case it
destroys the 2a0 hyper Edge
and creates these this pair of hyper
edges correct
yeah
so this unique
ugly symbols I understand you can
canonicalize but I'm saying you've got
this thing and it's event
before canonicalization destroys 2a0 and
produces these
right
and in the end you've got a giant vat of
events in the world
that you then have to find causal
connections between
but you're in in that vat of events
there are several things you can do okay
so in the states you're canonicalizing
the states so two states which have
which are the same in particular for
example there's some State down here
that's the same as some State over here
presumably
right that state there has two different
representations in terms of hypographs
but it can it can be canonicalized the
same right right the same is true of
events that there could be two events
that have different representations in
terms of the connector nodes or actually
these are basically eeves atoms of
existence so to speak every one of those
every one of those elements is a name
yeah
so basically uh what was saying is
foreign
s and eems in their natural state are
non-commericalized you know every every
atom of existence ever generated in the
history of everything is unique
that is its nature
but now what you're doing is you could
canonicalize across States you could
canonicalize across events or you can
canonicalize across both where I'm
claiming you go to patronette as a
result
right and you know do you agree with all
of this
I'm not sure about the better net but
yeah okay fine all right let me let me
just look that up because I do remember
that that
um
uh
I didn't see it in the rouliad post but
you do mention it in the
multi-computation post
oh that's the place that was the place
thank you yeah
um
what do do you understand what it says
though
um let's see
yeah you say um
a token event graph can be rolled up
into what amounts to a petri net by
completely deduplicating all instances
of equivalent tokens
but don't say anything about events
no no
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yes that's the difference okay the point
is in this case we are deduplicating
uh States
a state is a collection of tokens
right when we make the token event graph
this thing here
yeah every token here will be separated
right Nick
the fact that this is a single node is
the collecting of tokens into States
right
so then what's happening in the in the
Petri net
is that every
is that the tokens wherever they might
appear whatever States they might appear
in are being deduplicated
right so I mean what we have here let's
just let's just write a couple of notes
here I mean what we have I'm going to
scribble on this what we have here is
we've got
Okay so we've got the Eames
you know atoms whatever we call them
we're calling themes
um yes we've got tokens
and tokens are collections of eems
and there are ordered collections of
Eames
AKA relations between Eames
okay and that that's what you're
representing by these lists here
right
do you agree
then we've got States
which are
are unordered
collections of tokens
do you agree
they are ordered only by virtue of the
knitting of their aims
not necessarily collection you can
have some procedure to combine tokens
into a state
well okay but okay so look there's going
to be a function hold on one second so
then we've got then we've got okay now
next we have events
which are
well we've got rules somewhere in this
whole thing okay what are the rules say
the rules
are basically uh they consume tokens
and generate new ones
do you agree
that's the basic operation of the rules
here
yep
okay so events
knit together
consumed and generated tokens to uh no
consumed yes consumed and generated
tokens
is that right
yeah they have input and output right
they each they correspond to
an instance a rule application
right
okay so now
the other thing the next things we have
are
okay so token equivalence function
token equivalence
if we do that leads to Petri Nets
but we're not usually usually we're not
doing token equivalence so that's what
one thing these are the operations we
have to do okay collecting
tokens into States
that's the operation that is basically
you know EG construction of space-time a
construction of space brother is that
kind of operation
right in the construction of space
there's lots of disembodied hyper edges
that connect atoms of existence and to
make them into space you have to find a
way to collect those tokens into states
which in your case here you're doing by
daisy chaining them together to make
strings
do you agree
oh yeah but the the over the outer list
shouldn't be necessarily ordered because
you can reconstruct it from the links no
no absolutely absolutely
you know this is okay collect tokens
into States and the you know the states
are unordered collections we already
said this here are unordered collections
of tokens
right
okay so then we've got
uh
okay then we have state equivalence
which is a quite separate
right
State equivalence
is okay so what we've got actually
there's a there's a problem here because
we actually have two kinds of beams
we have
kind of generated variable
beams
versus what we might call symbol table
Eaves
right a symbol table eem is a
canonically named Like A or B
which has a central name
am I making sense
as opposed to the generated variables
here
which are which can be renamed
well it's strictly speaking you can get
rid of those payloads and replace them
with another link to our
special hype page
I understand in principle you could
replace a by a single Loop and B by
double Loop for example yeah
right but this is a way okay so symbol
table eems
so symbol table aims
are essentially a summary
of a small
hypergraph
can be made that can be
can be
thought of
as providing a summary of a small
hypergraph so in the case of the matter
mathematics thing that this is like
phishing you know true or false
out of
you know the Sea of Eves
I'm making sense it's like having some
canonical peace that we interpret as
true or false and then we name it that
way and the thing that we're generating
here but as well we could have just said
this thing really is an incredibly low
level object that doesn't have that
you know that doesn't yet have that
structure I don't understand that
actually okay let me let me let me say
that I think this is a useful point
um
I just don't understand how an aim can
summarize a hyper graph because a
hypergraph is is composed of Eames you
see oh no I'm just saying that that the
whole point is that we we're saying that
here for example
we're just all I'm saying is that we
could write that in terms of a hypograph
I'm saying you have two identical
hypographs and one of them represents
true one represents false and we're
writing those as true and false but we
could equally well write them as little
hypographs
that's all I'm saying yeah but I
wouldn't call that an e it's confusing
scale wise because the hypographs have
to be composed of individual you know
you call them atoms well fine physical
ideas yeah okay so we need another name
I mean what I'm calling symbol table
aims is okay so these are not tokens
because a token is a whole one of these
things these are I don't know what we
call them we call them you know uh
placeholders named neems
I will like make the separate
category of things at all I know it's
confusing yes I agree but but guys guys
otherwise every eem is renameable the a
is not renameable
it's true it is a different thing it is
like an element of the symbol table
what do you want to call it I mean it's
a it's a it's an anchor of some kind
that's right that's what I was going to
say yeah that's funny
um summarize one more time Stephen what
it does summarize this idea just for my
benefit again okay so what I'm saying is
what Nick is pointing out is that you
never need these things
you can always just make them out of
unique hypographs
okay
but we are making them as a we're using
A and B but it's more convenient to
write a and b than to write single Loop
and double Loop and so create a single
Loop in a double Loop
so
uh
right I mean that's a bad name for them
we need a name for these things because
they are the things they are these
things like eems that have a built-in
meaning versus themes but they're also
they're they're exactly but they're aims
that have a unique where there can be
many copies of them that's what's
confusing
because there are many many A's
otherwise these ones and twos and things
there's only one of them ever
and any attempt to any any renaming is
just sort of in the eye of the Observer
otherwise the other the normal Eames are
utterly unique
yes
or something
because it's a token that has
I'm not sure it's a very convincing sub
token I was thinking of something like
sub token but I don't think that's um uh
anyway I think we need a name for these
things I mean that I mean so here like
this is for Strings and when you
actually think of a string you you only
really care about the middle
character in these triplets yes it's the
case that for different kinds of
hypographs that you don't have that
distinction absolutely absolutely in the
typical wolf model type hypergraph there
is no anchor object
it's not there it's just one twos and
threes and everything can connect to
everything
just an arbitrary hyper Edge I mean in
other words these could be if this was a
graph every one of these would just be a
pair and there'd be nothing in the
middle
there'd be no tag
a tag is too generic a name I'm not sure
what this should be called we need a
name for this anyway
um
uh okay so let's keep going for a second
I think that's a useful summary
um in the bronchial graph
okay so in this case you have not
specified affiliation for this partial
graph right
it's the second one I mean
well what does second mean and some
cosmological resp frame or something
oh yeah this step basically
right it's like uh what we've done
before but yeah
because I'm doing everything with multi
object it's like a more lower level
thing there's a you can ask from a multi
to get a list of foliations and
foliation is just a list of another
other multis on each step how do I get a
list of foliations from this multi
you first you ask for a multi-object as
before
okay so there I compute the multi
now how do I get the list of photos just
just the foliations property of multi
yeah
and you can give it a list a number of
steps
and they're inside there's some extra
information and there's a list of held
multis so I guess the initial one second
one if you ask for more you get
what the heck is this
so
what are the elements for foliation the
elements of a foliation are presumably
events is that correct
that are supposed to be simultaneous
is that right
the content here is anti-chains
yeah each much is there is an anti-chain
you start with the initial one
then you generate a new one
and you can it's deterministic you don't
apply your rule
on the same hyperbridge hypergraph twice
um well yeah right you use up you're
checking off hyper you're checking off
these edges if I'm not mistaken
and saying I've used that in a foliation
I've used that in affiliation now the
next foliation has to use new edges
right
every every success of foliation has to
use a fresh set of edges
correct
right right
so we kind of for each mood you can ask
its current events
so it's shown there in the summary box
shows the states the hypergraphs but you
cannot it also holds the rules and you
can ask for what are the events at this
point
okay but I mean basically affiliation is
a is a
is some kind of partial order collection
of it's just anti-chance and a post set
this thing is a post set and it's a it's
it's a particular choice of anti-chains
believe
yeah and default you can also give it to
like a third argument the function your
canonicalizing function don't apply but
you hold it's an identity
but for the actual causal graph that is
generated there from this foliations
it's going to be canonical
um
I didn't quite understand that let's
just keep going because unfortunately
going to run out of time
which is a shame what is a causal
branchial graph
oh I know what that is it's it's a new
thing
no it's something we considered before
but we decided wasn't going to be
interesting but maybe it is interesting
it's it's the bronchial graph of it is
the foliation of the events right
so the bronchial graph made instead of
looking for
in the token event graph
a the branchial graph
connect States
who can just tell you the procedure how
it generated it's it's not exactly
computed with the same procedure with
the computer ancestry of something of
events
it connects events with this branch of
age when the
been produced with an overwhelming rule
that's the condition
so then you can say that when they're
connected to the sage they were actually
connected so it's like an entanglement
or whatever
if there is a rule application that
applied to one state and produced
two states but those events were
spatially disconnected there's no going
to be another wrap and there's no going
to be I understand this is essentially a
race condition
this when this when there is a branch
Shield when there is a causal branchial
Edge it represents a race condition
between two events
yeah because those two events what's
that I was thinking of it as a
correlation because it also propagates
it further
because all those events are bigger than
separate branches and you if you ask to
continue this graph
further you kind of you have to
propagate this correlation between all
of the events in the those branches
I think I understand all right let's
take a little look here expressions
okay what is this system
okay
why is that conditioned so that that's
that's the identity element
why is that the only that's the only one
that does a generator variable
all the other ones are just cons why
does oh I see that doesn't because it is
just generating an identity
hmm
interesting
okay so what happens in
just just so I understand if I were
gonna do my trivial
I'm really confused by this in this case
how does it compile that
so you've got a compiler that goes from
certain left-hand sides
so let me try a different case which is
numbers
yeah okay
it converts Arbiter expression
okay how does it do that I mean so so
okay so if I take my my favorite
um I want to say
what should I do I should say
and I should do a pattern
n goes to n plus one
n goes to 2N
yeah
and then we start with one and we do
three steps
and then we say States graph
is a steps calls into into properties
you only have two arguments for the
Constructor
what the heck is that
why did it not to duplicate
uh I suspect because it's actually not
too there but
two times one
okay well how do I get it to make that
simplify that
I'm not sure it's
like that's the whole point this is this
is what state equivalence is all about
what you've done is you've got the
nominal expression that has made is used
to generate that element
but now the whole point is one aspect of
State equivalence is running the
evaluator and seeing what you get
yeah just replace each vertices
with a from linked hypergraph
and give it an expression what what are
you talking about
how do I make this okay this didn't work
right because in this case you've got
some canonicalizer that canonicalizes
these typographs but these typographs
you are not successfully canonicalizing
like that that is a hypergraph as well
you know to writing is one times two
well I think it's a mistake because I
have forgot to pass a type
okay all right but there should become
any questions to expression not the
hyper graph there
can I fix that in some easy way
I can fix it like in one minute and you
have to reinstall the pocket well I'm
gonna run out of time unfortunately
let's take a look here okay so then use
vertex replace on that and make post
okay what you've got here okay so now
you've got combinators here
but it doesn't care does it what
what the heck is that
there's a some treecraft to be done in
order to kind of make a sub values
compilation with constructs
okay
wait a minute so this is going like all
the way with hypergraphs is that right
yes that's what it's doing
it's really it's turning every
expression and this by the way in my
commentator stuff this has to do with
presumably the you know all this tree
all this weird stuff about tree pseudo
events and so on that's what this is
this is a representation of all the
weird tree pseudo event stuff
um
okay
well this is quite this is this is what
I was hoping you were going to build for
the last time of many weeks okay this is
all looking quite nice I mean there's
more we have to understand here
um
okay if we look at multi-way system
it has a few other capabilities right
and by the way if you run larger
examples is it going to work properly or
not here
well it works better for hypergraphs
that's certainly
at certain okay but I mean if I take a
large example of um
I mean a string let me take a large
example here
um
so okay for Strings because the
compilation to hyperglass it's an
additional overhead so yeah
but if you want a multi-way system for
hypergraphs it actually works better
anyway let's say we take this guy here
it's otherwise known as pretty hairy
object
um
okay that was a hundred steps but let's
take your thing
and um oh and I assume you have some
analog of States graph structure
no just I don't think that you have you
need it you just vertex shape function
goes no no that's no good that's no good
we need something simpler than that
right we need we need some way I mean
it's probably not very well designed
here but we need something that does not
involve every single piece of code being
festooned with you know vertex shape
function nonsense
I do have a better design in mind than a
second property
I don't know I have not thought about it
okay so here now we make a multi-way
object which is this thing
and then here
we would say
States graph
let's say 30
and then then how do I make this I say
you can pass it after the 30. okay what
do I say vertex shape function automatic
I don't like
it's just too common to want to do the
other thing
okay we already lost the game this is
unbelievably slow
yeah that
yes we need to figure out how to speed
this up
maybe it's compilation maybe it's
something else this is this is not gonna
work this is way way way too slow
okay whereas here
boom
okay
so that's that's one thing we need to
look at is you know
it's good to have the functionality but
we need to make it faster
um
and I guess
I mean in terms of the actual structures
you're making here
well I mean
what is the relationship between this
and a multi-way trace graph
anybody understand that
what's the relationship between your
token I mean so in other words here
we're going all the way with with
hypergraphs as opposed to expressions
because in a trace graph
its nodes and it's basically raw
material are expressions
right
yeah rather than
um
well the only difference is you just
don't have rules corresponding to down
values that are
automatically
extracted for each state
at each step
right but as I said as I've said about
500 times we need these things like find
replace power
that are basically will operate on these
multi-way objects right
and presumably that's straightforward to
build now
is that true
it depends how generally you want to go
because if you want this is supposed to
support the rules
very generally
and if you want to find replace path
that's actually have a reverse Direction
I also had a prototype that I have like
reverse rules that supports arbitrary
patterns
okay
I unfortunately this is the cost of
previous meetings that have have not
gone so well this meeting got scheduled
as a pure one-hour block
um there's much more we could do here
um and we need to continue with this but
I can't do it right the second
um
so uh
we have to wrap up here but this is this
is very nice
it's good and and let's I mean but
please can you figure out how to get
like the find replace path type stuff we
got the issue with speed here what other
things do you think are the frontiers of
this
well
I was thinking of how to actually make
incorporate history
into that
it's like Max and his set replace
bucket to have this multi-history thing
what does that mean
well now you're just asking some
different kind of graph properties but
what if you actually have
to have this the same object that you
wanna run a few times and it remembers
when it went so that you can continue
something like that oh I see
exfoliation you mean that the multi that
instead of the multi just producing a
graph the multi can cache six steps of
of multiness which is very similar to
The Lazy situation
yeah
yeah right but I think you should try
and get the thing here the uncached
unlazy version
you know so that it's nice and efficient
and so it has full functionality before
worrying about the case where it's you
know it has lazy caching in it
because I think that's a factored issue
dealing with the laser caching stuff
all right I need to run here
um but this is all good and to be
continued
see you guys later
bye